[Music]
uh
today we're back to the [ __ ]
garbage that's this [ __ ] plan and i'm
really goddamn sick of it
um
first can i get a quick update here
because our friend um
stuttering john our friend stuttering
john
you remember him
stern show
closeted gay guy
um
john tweeted out
apparently being an avid supporter
of progressive values has hit me in the
wallet
oh no
you know he opens it up like a cartoon
and a moth comes out i thought being a
divorced alcoholic who has to substitute
teach on the side is what's hitting you
in the wallet
i thought having house sparks on your
show every day was hitting you in the
wallet should i got bubba sparks um i
thought it was just being a talentless
hack
virgie
oh i'm sorry no you were right you're
right because actually you're correct
but i mean come on show some love
uh he was on uh on stern uh has hit me
in the wallet the all media comedy club
and uh
mystique street in corpus christi
alameda comedy club mesquite street
corpus christi
it's in corpus christi texas
texas both cancelled my gigs
because of threats trolls call with
threats of violence and give them a bad
review time to quit something i love
guys here's the deal right
see here's the thing is that john is
such a such a progressive such an
outspoken anti-trump progressive
that the um hardcore right-wing
republican stronghold of alameda
california
has froze up in rebellion against him
and said john
enough not on our watch you know what
man not on our watch we're progressive
here in california but i mean jesus hit
the brakes a little bit man
second tweet
i'm sad to say that the comedy club
succumbed to the pressure of my haters
and canceled my gig there apparently my
trolls threatened uh them with giving
them a one star review on yelp and
google
uh this is the second club that is
cancelled hate fine
but [ __ ] with one's livelihood
yeah
um
this
only applies to people
who don't sell tickets
it just doesn't like royce just said
before the show he's like oh i'm sorry
so dave chappelle can't get gigs
anywhere they tried to literally [ __ ]
stamp him it was royce's first thing
that came out of his mouth he's like
they tried to snap him and he's still
getting gigs so
if you sell louis ck louis ck
blocked a doorway and jerked off in
front of chicks
i mean there's some places that aren't
going to touch them but if louis c.k
contacts your theater and goes it's a
direct show i'm running everything i
just want to have it for the weekend
you're going to let them happen by the
way let me correct that louis ck never
blocked the door
he asked a jerk
harvey weinstein however did block a
door and then he went on to make clerks
too
and that's not to not to mention not to
mention matt lauer yeah which clerks too
is the most egregious part of that and
then matt really more really i would
think it'd be the rapes and not to be
confused with matt lauer who had a trap
door
instead of locking a door he hitting mr
burns trap door the moment that someone
was installing that in his office you
don't think anybody went hey why does
matt need like a trap door in his in his
office by the way he didn't really ever
trapped him but he did have a
closer door with a button under his desk
that he had they lock the door of the
office with a butt which again you'd
still if you were installing that go
like
is he going to be are people going to be
getting whacked in here or is he a super
villain it was that or they were going
to stall it hatch that opens up and
drops them down to the pit with the
snakes because my brain wouldn't even
immediately go to rape but if i'm a
contractor and i'm working on this i'd
go
hey uh
you think matt lauer is whacking people
in here like it's like is this like uh
it's like that die-hard movie where they
laid a plastic down on the ground
so hold on
then somebody asked them yeah go ahead
virginia i'm sorry i just a little
little context on this further
the the alameda comedy club
hosts a
host a like a drag brunch show like
three nights a week or three days a week
listen john
listen john
we'll host the drag brunck show all day
we'll even invite kids
but you're a little too progressive for
us pal
yeah he's he's playing his progressive
values but this place literally hosts
like drag brunches john we got drag
queens to come in here and drink mimosas
on sunday and perform abortions yeah for
free pro bono
we're progressive but dude you gotta
slow your roll
we can't sell tickets
so then somebody asked them sorry john
dante fired you too yep he did dante by
the way that's uh dante from aew
it's oh i thought it was dante from
clark dante martin the alabama albino
black guy
sorry john dante fired you too yep he
did then he had the audacity to side
with the club wait what i thought you
fired him
that snake in the grass nope he dropped
me and said i was unbookable now that my
trolls are doing this
no but again
do the trolls hurt your situation yes of
course however
if you're making money for a place
they generally don't care
some places [ __ ] live for that
controversy